what are you reading outsiders
it's not my thing young folks with
outside powers traveling the world
knocking bad guys on their asses hey
everybody this is gonna be my black
lightning episode 3 video read any good
Batman in the outsiders Comics recently
this is the actual comic that they
flashed in the episode probably because
the character Lady Eve is a part of that
story and she debuted as a character in
the episode this is the person playing
Lady Eve so obviously it's a little bit
different from what they did during the
outsiders comic book but your comic book
costumes bunch of names thrown around
like Supergirl that threw everybody for
a loop they're like wait a minute
how is this connected to all those other
shows as their name dropping people like
Supergirl so I'll try to explain you
know what that means for the world of
the show and what possibly exists like
the way that they're treating it there's
also a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber and share the video
using those tools on the watch page
totally love that hygiene PSA that Black
Lightning gave to her daughter's
boyfriend before he almost lost the
ability to walk apparently by the end of
the episode so feel kind of bad for him
probably not what he was talking about
when he said that he and his daughter
should probably pump the brakes on their
relationship but most of you who have
been following the Black Lightning
series probably know about the grace
Troy character from the comics so in the
outsiders comic books black lightnings
older daughter Thunder is in a
relationship with grace Choi who's an
Amazon so obviously that's a little bit
different they're going a little more
real-world with this so unless there's
some trickery going on in the series
she's not going to develop powers
there's just gonna be thunder and
they'll eventually start going out I
think that was kind of the idea of the
episode is that they slowly form a bond
she breaks up with her other girlfriend
the funny thing about the bar that she
works at the ruby red lipstick bar great
lesbian pun is that when she's name
dropping their cosplay party she's like
you can dress up as anybody like
Supergirl she dresses up like Catwoman
Grace Choi is dressed up like the halo
character who's also part of the
outsiders team in the comics so all that
talk about costumes is probably just to
tee up the idea of Anissa creating her
own
book costume for the Thunderer persona
regardless of when she decides to take
that name it'll be interesting to see
because they don't have a cisco on this
TV show to give people comic-book names
it'll be funny to see how she goes about
calling herself Thunder and which person
gives her that name but I'm guessing
it's either gonna be Black Lightning
himself or it's gonna be the grace Choi
character because usually the person
that gives them the name is somebody
that's really close to them either in an
emotional way or a relationship like
Lois Lane is the person that gives Clark
Kent the Superman name but as for
connectedness to the larger superhero
community I think when she named drop
Supergirl as a cosplay option she was
talking about comic book super girl
because comic books exist in this world
like she literally holds up a comic book
so I think that's what she was talking
about I don't think there's an actual
Supergirl that exists on whatever earth
that black lightning is taking place on
in the multiverse so for now remember
there are 53
earths in the DC TV universe as far as
we know so I just kissing the black
lightning is on a separate earth where
there is no green arrow there is no
flash there is no Superman or Supergirl
so the other kind of funny storyline
that ends up in a really tragic way is
the other daughter lightning that's her
name from the comics so it's gonna get
confusing talking about black lightning
then talking about lightning like which
one are you talking about so the younger
daughter just like flat-out has that
funny conversation where she's like I'm
totally gonna be doing it this weekend
this is the time and date exactly that
I'm gonna be getting it on with my
boyfriend obviously it didn't go down
that way but you can kind of see that
they're creating the need for her to be
a superhero too like they want her to go
through this tragedy it realized why
it's so important that people stand up
for what they believe in that's why it
was so important that his daughters
watch Black Lightning take down those
criminals at the end of the episode like
oh wow
they're seeing this person and it's
inspiring to them like the older
daughter is already on the tipping point
of becoming a superhero she has that
long conversation the younger daughter
is just at an earlier stage of that in
fact but we don't know when she's gonna
get her powers but she will get powers
eventually before we knew that the
boyfriend was gonna lose the ability to
walk almost I was actually thinking that
maybe having sex would partially
activate those powers because usually
like in the classic comics especially
like x-men and groups with like a whole
bunch of really young
people that develop powers it becomes
kind of a metaphor for their sexuality
so like anytime a teenage superhero just
suddenly hits a certain age they get
superpowers it's kind of like a metaphor
for them becoming sexually active and
all these biological systems powering on
that aren't there when you're much much
younger we're really only in episode 3
at this point next week's episode is
actually called Black Jesus so I'm
guessing that it'll probably be the end
of the season or the last couple of
episodes before is he Thunder in that
comic book costume they teased her maybe
telling her mother about her powers but
she sort of shied away from that
eventually they're gonna find out like
grace Joy's whole big speech about how
being a superhero is lonely it's just
the tip off the yeah black lightning
we'll find out then separately grace
Choi will probably find out so Thunder
will have her own small little cell team
around her before she actually starts
doing stuff with black lightning because
it sounds like she's gonna try and be a
superhero on her own before her family
finds out so anytime there's a long
conversation about how it sucks to be a
superhero because you can't tell people
your identity
it's just foreshadowing for people close
to her eventually finding out so she
won't be lonely the real WTF at the end
of the episode though is Peter gambi
deleting the footage of Tobias whale so
that Black Lightning won't see it like
he says sorry Jefferson I don't think
that's because he's working for Tobias
well I think it's because he likes what
Black Lightning is doing helping clean
up the community and if he sees Tobias
whale he might make a beeline for him
before he's ready like you take on Darth
Vader before you're ready to fight him
like Empire Strikes Back you don't want
black lightning to get one of his hands
chopped off you could actually make a
couple Star Wars references to because
he keeps stabbing people in their hands
so it'll be interesting to see if he
tries to stop Black Lightning in one of
his hands you also get a little more of
the police department being really upset
with Black Lightning the police chief is
adamant that he's not on their payroll
but he doesn't fight the Reverend when
he says that the cops are corrupt
so we'll probably find out who some of
those dirty cops are pretty soon but
there are 13 episodes remember this is
really just the beginning of the season
but let me know in the comments if you
spotted any other big Easter eggs that I
didn't mention in the video just let me
know what you think of the show so far
music is fantastic as always
and speaking of Supergirl stuff because
I didn't do Supergirl video
actually did the full-on lexo suit they
just teased it last season I was waiting
for somebody to actually put it on so
maybe we'll get to see it again
eventually but they also dropped a
computo brainiac easter egg and they
named drop Superman again but you know
because of what's going on in the movies
and the fact that they're ramping up for
Man of Steel - and Henry Cavill is gonna
be featured in a lot of the upcoming DC
movies I think the TV people are being
forced to dial it way back on the idea
of Superman in a costume on TV despite
the fact that they have the new Superman
prequel series that they're developing
for the DC streaming service I've
already done a video explaining what's
going on with that TV show so I'll post
a link at the end of the video
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last video if Z please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll just name a new winner when
I post a new DC video so all kinds of
comic book stuff dropping this week
click here to learn all about flash war
in that brand new flash trailer and you
can click here for that video about the
metropolis TV series thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight